okay let's talk about russian spots
here's a story about russian spies okay
on page three
and and i'm curious to know how much
credibility you're giving to this one uh
russian spies among us a look at new
york compound that houses kremlin's
intelligence officer the complex
known as russian diplomatic compound in
new york city's riverdale neighborhood
has often been the subject of
speculation surrounding the building's
purpose and residence practices the
building is home to russian diplomats
many of whom work in the united states
as intelligence officers there are two
types of intelligence officers those who
pose a symmetrical threat and those who
pose
an asymmetrical threat those working in
new york and living in the compound and
working at the mission in the united
nations are under diplomatic cover it's
called a symmetrical threat we know
they're here they're diplomats under
diplomatic coverage so they actually
have all the privileges of diplomats and
they've been caught conducting coverage
so they actually
espionage against our country you can't
throw them in jail because they're
diplomats but they're different from
undercover operatives who are not
uh under the official cover and are in
the united states those who pose as
asymmetrical
uh threat undercover operatives such as
jack barsky who operate under
non-official cover under false pretenses
with fake names
what do you want to say that article
fails to mention the third category
what's that
people who are
not undercover they're not
assuming it's not another identity they
work officially as
as journalists
uh business people
students
right they they
they have an official reason to be here
but then they spy and i think those are
the ones right now that uh
uh that we we have to be aware of uh
because you know we are very open
country how many how many chinese
exchange students do we have
uh in and i guarantee you
russia and china
and all those dictatorships know exactly
who is going abroad
and they all will be talked to
so there's there's a good there's a good
reason to believe that there are
currently more
people in the united states russians
that
are engaged in espionage than they were
in my time
because there wasn't in my time there
wasn't that free exchange of you know
students and
teachers and uh
and business people uh
back and forth
in those days we had the two types the
asymmetric threat
us and there were very few of us very
few
in the
undercover yes undercover deep cover yes
deep cover uh
in in the 80s according to mitrokin uh
there were
early 80s late 70s there were about 10
10 of us that were
uh trained and sent to the u.s
10.
uh and there were a couple of other
prior to the uh to that period there
were um there were a couple of other uh
efforts to bring
those types of agents into the u.s and
they never amounted too many okay
uh
so
and and here's here's one other
difference between
the
uh kgb and
putin's intelligence services
the kgb was very solicitous of their
agents they were
they
did not like it when an agent was caught
they weren't you know they they and and
if we if and when we were caught they
did everything to get us out
uh putin
enjoys when we catch people
because you know
it scares us you know how many more of
those are there
i guarantee you quite a few oh he likes
it when we catch people why not because
it makes him gives a message it gives a
message that we got on the inside yes
that we're here it's game we're not
going
how many
reverse it how many people how many
americans or you know people on the
american side of things
or on the eu side of things even are
implanted in russia or even china for
that matter
i would that's this is an educated guess
far fewer
far fewer they're better at it than we
are yes they are and um
you know or it's just easier to blend in
in america how many people want to live
in russia how
how uh bernie sanders
yes and how many people would uh you
know it would be a sacrifice as opposed
to coming to the united states you get a
good life and you do something patriotic
for your country
that also played a role uh
for me signing up in those days but like
you how many people fall in love with
the benefits of living in america and
say
kgb life ain't for me anymore i'm just
going to stay here for a while
yes but you've got to be careful there's
always relatives in back home
and you may be married
with children uh so
and it's not that easy to defect and uh
you know and if you want to play
the double agent game that's very
dangerous and the people that uh the the
this category of uh
official cover but but not
under diplomatic protection
uh
this category is not well trained they
don't get one you say when in 2010
there were like 10
uh
svr agents russian agents were arrested
by the
by the fbi and they were like very
poorly trained there's a there's a short
video an fbi video on youtube where you
can see
some of their operations and when i saw
this for the first time i was screaming
at the tv you can't do this this is
wrong so if you enjoyed this little
segment from the podcast click over here
to watch the entire podcast and if
you're not subscribed to the channel
please do so take care everybody
[Music]